so we can start right well just a few
words about myself for you to understand
why why am I here and why I do this this
kind of job so now I'm working as a
software engineer in it scraping hub and
I was born in Yekaterinburg in Russia in
the middle of Russia and I spent five
years at Yandex Yandex is a Russian
Google and number one search system in
Russia and I spent five years in search
quality Department I worked on social
search working with Twitter data and
work on question answer search and
improved snippets snippets are short
annotations when you see search results
you should see short notations of the
document during that time it was a
pretty awesome time we've had the whole
Twitter stream that means like Yandex
just bought Twitter for one year and we
were able to work with this data and we
tried we tried to build a fresh search
you know recent recent recent results so
when you when something some has
happened in the world we had to use
Twitter data to get the best up-to-date
result so that was a pretty tough
challenge and later I spent two years at
Avast Antivirus which is like the most
popular inch of virus in the world at
the moment they have about 200 millions
users and for them I made automatic
false positive solving so then then
antivirus catches some clean stuff user
is able to report that back and this is
became a big problem for for virus
laboratories so we had to somehow solve
these issues I built machine learn based
automatic fast positive solving
so it's grating hub Wichern web content
into useful data we do about two billion
requests per month and also perform some
focused roles and broad crawls so we
call broad crawl when you do not crawl a
single website but you crawl a number of
websites it could be like hundreds so we
call such a crawler both broad crawl and
the possible usage for broad crawl is
lead generation so you search web for a
contact information of businesses and
you somehow aggregate this the next
thing is topical crawling for example
you are interested like in patchwork or
maybe speed cars and you want to collect
the documents about that topic so the
broad CRO is a much more better way to
do this when for example using Google
because Google is quite limited and
they're biased they have their own
interests so they do not show all the
content on the Internet the third most
very important thing is news analysis
for example if you want to analyze
what's what's happening around some
person or some company so to perform a
broad crawl is like the way to go and
were like few less popular usages also
plagiarism detection sentiment analysis
profile business data due to engines and
in DARPA there is a tracking of criminal
activity and lost persons so they crawl
web forums analyze images and try to
connect the pieces so just a quick
example in inscribing hub we had a
customer search global gallery so they
wanted to build a global art gallery so
the problem was to collect
eleven thousands of to crawl 11
thousands of online general jewelleries
and extract picture information except
picture like description and such a
field so we were not able to do this
manually to crawl single website so we
had to had to build an exchange
extractor which could deal with like any
kind of website so Fronteras is a
problem framework and here's
recep's how it can be used so for
example if you want to grow multiple
websites and automate such a kind of
data collection or if you want to grab
the internet segment like I use grab
because well this is kind of a synonym
for line your scan and typical crawling
and I will dimension that and the last
thing is extracting data from arbitrary
document so the first thing is multiple
websites data collection if you have for
example a set of websites and you want
to crawl them and extract some data from
them and then you need somehow to manage
the resources like you want to paralyze
certain pages or you want to somehow do
revisiting to refresh the data so that's
this is that use case so Frontera can be
used to crawl in parallel and scale the
process and schedule revisiting at the
moment with fixed time but this logic
can be customized and it can be used to
purchase Asian grepping of Internet
segment it is I already mentioned this
regarding typical crawling for example
if you
if you want to collect some data like it
could be it could be anything
maybe maybe you collect the usage of the
English words to build a language model
of some something like this or you
collect the contacts information so this
is a methodology how it how it can be
done
so there are gestures and they do have
zone files that means zone file is
having all the information about the
domains in a certain zone in commodore
dotnet common dotnet Verisign american
company is the one who is responsible
for registering such a domains so you
can request access to zone file and then
use twist zone files to establish crawl
then you have to set up from there and
distributed mode implement some kind of
attacks pros to sink in spider code and
output items we have matched pages
something like this
topical crawling can be done with
document topic classifier and CT list so
before you do some topical crawling you
have to somehow establish the topic so
that means you have to train the
classifier it could be just a vocabulary
of some words or it could be something
more complex
just with analyzing the content or maybe
analyzing previous crawl steps could be
also analyzing urals
and so next thing it works like if it
was classified as positive and just in
crawler extracting links and following
them and if it is negative and it
doesn't make much sense to file all
these links and it can be just skipped
so that that way we just push a crawler
towards a topic we are interested in
this kind of Mythology can be extended
so you could also classify the links
itself so you don't have to follow any
link but only certain links which is
like much more fine approach and it
works much better last thing is
extracting data from arbitrary document
this is a tough problem it can be solved
like hundred in two hundred percent of
cases but when you then you have some
when you spend some time like weeks you
know it's possible to achieve some some
good level of quality so it can be seen
as a structured prediction problem so
there are conditional random fields
algorithm and hidden Markov models
you basically annotate the sequence of
tokens and HTML tags and then like
surrounding the data fields you need and
then this can be used to train the model
and later predict these fields in unseen
documents and in scraping crap we built
that obstruct the library and replicator
Firefox extension so let's this move
forward and we Frontera to test the
framework which right to establish a
broad crawl of a Spanish Internet and
collect some statistics about other
costs and at the same time tests have
Frontera performs on a scale so the task
was to crawl the Spanish web collect the
hosts and correct and versailles the
statistics only dot es zone and 30g was
bred first so we don't crawl deeply in
the web site we
crawl like breath to so it means we
don't need to crawl the whole website we
just need to briefly walk so the
finishing condition was like hundred
documents from one host maximum and of
course the price was very we are very
sensitive to the price of this project
so we try to save money so here's some
statistics how Internet looks like this
is all collected from Oh ect
Communications Outlook report and you
can see that there are domains like 15
million in German and we have like one
in the house that was in 2014 and
regarding the hosts it also like was not
that big I would say Internet segment so
it was made made intentional because we
didn't want it to grow some kind of a
big Internet
because we had no had no resources for
that and we want this task to be somehow
solvable list so we are not Google and
as you see Russian internet is somewhere
in the middle between Spanish and German
so our solution is based on a few few
frameworks
the first one is scrappy our our own
child it was mainly used for network
operations and next one is Apache Kafka
that was our database database and it
was used with its features for tracking
the customer offsets and partitioning of
the topic storage was used HBase because
we needed efficient random access
line your skinning and we need it to be
scalable and we also use like snappy and
twisted snappy to get efficient
compression and twist it to make a
synchronous primitives in workers and in
some back-end since crappy and here's
the architecture so I would start with
spiders so we put some CG euros in the
spiders and crawl starts from them so
first we crawled and then links
extracted from them came to the spider
LOC later spider lock is consumed by a
set of strategy workers and DB workers
strategy workers do consume the spider
law like all these extracted links and
make decision if these links have to be
scheduled for perfect crawling or we
already crawled these links and it
doesn't need to be crawled again so all
links which needs to be scheduled are
getting some score realization and this
score is propagated to the scoring clock
along with a link then all that
information is consumed by DB worker
which does scheduling it set by itself
and then then schedules then new batches
are generated by DB worker new batches
for crawlers and then these batches
consumed by scrappy spiders we do have a
separate queue for every spider because
we want to be polite so well that needs
to be explained some some more because
when you have when you crawl a single
website from more than one spider it's
hard to be polite to that website
because you can't control the request
rate
so we want to control the request rate
so that way because because of that we
had to somehow separate hosts by spiders
and assign some group of host a single
spider and we did that with kefka topic
partitioning and separate queue in HBase
and DB worker for every partition and
every spider so it wasn't that easy we
solved some problems in involving like
changing your entire architecture and I
just walked through major of row major
problems so first thing we just we faced
this big and small host problem so
basically when you start crawling like a
single like some home page could
generate like thousands of followings
from the same website so if you if you
don't do some kind of realization that
would end up with flooding with a spider
with links from the same host and we
wanted to be polite to that host so we
introduced some delays like second or
half of a second between requests so
that means we just wasted resources
wasted time because spider was mostly
like waiting for the next request to
generate so it ended up as under use of
spider resources and it was solved the
additional per host queue and some
metering algorithm which like makes some
it like puts some pieces when when it it
tracks somehow how the host is like
loaded on spider so if if week you have
this host is pretty big we don't
generate new requests but if it's not so
we push some more so at the end we were
like able to parole if a single scrappy
spider in parallel from hundred web
hosts at the same time and it was
generating about 1200 documents per
minute so that was the solution was
basically to catch some euros from big
hosts in memory second thing we did
those DNS service from Amazon so yeah
that's because of we did breadth-first
actually when you do breadth-first a
crawler is tend to follow links from
from from websites which are external so
that requires a lot of DNS resolutions
so it end up with like been Incas for a
short amount of time and we just
switched to DNS mask to our own unit
server and we installed a single
instance on every crawling machine and
it worked pretty well with upstream to
vary zone openness huge DNS providers
the next thing is we had a problem of
DNS resolution at the moment in
operating systems the DNS resolution is
a blocking process when you do a system
call Linux system call like resolved
resolved like resolving name it blocks
and then it does requests it does
requests to the DNS server and waits for
the answer like for 50 milliseconds or
maybe more and
because of that we had a limited it was
like put well Scrappy's a synchronous
framework and such a generous resolution
was put in at red and that means we have
a thread pool and it had a limited size
so we had to somehow adjust a thread
pool to make it like bigger and then
adjust the amounts of resolution of her
Dainius names that doesn't make sense
when you do like crawling from 12
websites or 50 or from a single website
but when you crawl like from hundreds or
from thousands let's start to make
problems well the next issue was we
overload at HBase regular region service
we had a bit of a state check so when in
strategy worker when you receive a new
link you have to check was it grow old
or not what's the kind of state of it do
we have to crawl it for the next time or
not and we had so much such a queries so
just overloaded each base region servers
and the problem was solved with host
local fingerprint function for Cassini's
be in HBase so if you maybe who knows
HBase here okay there are some people so
for the rest I can explain how cashing
in HBase works all the data store ten
blocks so the idea was and blocks are
cached so when you request a single row
if it's not in the cache it's like it
reads a whole block from the from the
disk and this is expensive but the block
could be adjustable size like 64
megabytes or kiloton like yeah so it
could be quite big so the idea was
to put the states for a single website
in a single block of HBase so when we do
crawling we want to check links mostly
from the same website so we like if we
grow like 400 websites at parallel this
hundred websites they do slightly change
but they can be changed quickly so we
could make use of such a block caching
so the idea was to somehow tell HBase
put our links States of his links to the
same block so that was achieved if host
local fingerprint function for keys in
HBase it was like four bytes encoded
hostname and 16 bytes was encoded the
ural path so keys are sorted in HBase so
that way we get a hole like all the
links in the same block so later we had
to tune age base block cache to fit
average host states into one block and
just a rough numbers at the end we have
three terabytes of urals compressed and
we spent about 275 bytes per document so
the next problem was intensive network
traffic between workers sent and
spider-sense HBase so I saw the rates of
one gigabit per second
between our internal lon
so which is Eric we were using AWS and
which was quite close to the limits of a
network interface so we had to solve
that problem so it was soft with drift
compact protocol for HBase so which base
traffic became smaller
message compression in Kafka with snappy
so then we made some perfect weather and
traffic optimizations to HBase and we
introduced local state cash in strategy
worker so the state was checked in first
in the cash and then cash was flushed
inch base and to achieve that we also
divided spider LOC by host and each
worker consumed we're all hosts assigned
to it because we didn't want it to cash
to overlap otherwise it doesn't work
so here's the state cash design it's
actually pretty simple it's a dictionary
with fingerprint as a key and States as
the value so the state was like it is
not crawled it was crawled or it was
year old and we did like every four
thousand documents flushing and we also
flushed when it was like close to three
millions of items in the cache they also
did a flash to the each page but that
wasn't much it wasn't efficient and I
think we will introduce the least
recently used algorithm so it should be
much more better so here's how a
priority queue designed in DB Walker we
basically have a cell with an array of
Urals and scores and these cells they
are sorted by the well euros with the
same score they are grouped and
then they are sorted and when new euros
needs to be collected
they are just taken from the top so we
always consume the highest score first
and each cell has a fingerprint crc32
hostname and Ural and score so this
information later used to establish a
new request and hostname is used to be
as to build the queue of hosts and then
after one month of crawling we've got a
strike back of bacon small host problem
we just covered few very large web hosts
and they simply flooded our queue in the
storage so basically like the basic
comment to the queue is like give me say
1000 euros so we discovered hosts like
20 million of documents and there were
just all the all the other euros they
had much more smaller score so we were
concentrated under these large hosts so
again under use of spider resources and
we solved that problem they've two
MapReduce jobs first one is give
shuffling so you basically within the
same cell score like if you have cell
0.8 and you have a group of hosts for
with this court it was shuffled to
somehow put the big host under under
smaller ones and then we decided to
limit all host 200 documents maximum so
we did not growth always be
so result we discovered some biggest
some big websites like $80 or Rakuten or
various also yeah Eddie does should be a
big issue up there is also a big forum
well these are not the most popular
websites in Spanish Internet they are
just the biggest and big websites means
like it has a lot of pages and many
times it's not because has a lot of
pages it's both because it's badly
designed well but we did a kind of a
research so let's also result so we
found about 60,000 domains and we were
expecting about 600,000 and we crawled
about 46 millions of pages overall and
spent one and a half months and we found
22 websites with more than 50 million
pages so the question is wherever a
staff of web servers because we like got
10% from what we expected so here's the
pretty old model built by angry brother
from Yahoo research it's a kind of
generalization of how the internet looks
like so in the middle we have a strongly
connected component with means that in
this component each page is
interconnected with some other page by
means of other pages and in the in
component that means there are pages
which do link to strongly connected
component but don't have link back in
the out that means these components are
linked from strongly connected component
and don't link back to strongly
connected
and and there are also disconnected
components completely lurid tubes like
bypassing strongly connected component
and there are also various tendrils from
in and out component which do have like
incoming you're out coming links but
don't have opposite and the idea is in
the out links there are probably some
company websites which don't have to
link to the rest of Internet they just
don't need it in the in component where
are probably some new websites which are
not well-known yet so they don't linked
from strongly connected component yet so
here's the short statistics collected in
2005 how big the strongly connected
component is between some language so we
could see that Chinese strongly
connected component is pretty big and
they have relatively small in and out in
in Japanese it's quite opposite well
honestly it's data from the article and
it looks like it is based a bit so they
have probably some specific crawler
logic and you can't complete the trust
that date or you have to take it to some
grain of salt and here's the dynamics of
twelve years pretty fresh article
relatively fresh like 2014 but here our
old tendency is like first strongly
connected component to grow so that
means web became more interconnected
more and more with the time so my me why
am i explaining all this our feeling
that we used as a seed before we started
for all too much components too much
websites
out-out component so they were simply
not linked properly back to the whole
internet so that's why we got only 10%
so a few words about hardware
requirements and if you want to run like
distributor to crawl in from there and
scrape it you could get about 1,200
pages per minute from about 100 websites
in parallel spiders to workers ratio is
4 to 1 so it means for every four
spiders you have to put one worker 1
gigabytes of RAM for strategy worker
state cache and summarizing of that if
you want 12 spiders they will give you
like 15,000 pages per minute and this is
possible to achieve if free strategy
workers and 3db workers in total it will
all consume 18 course single process per
core so software requirements also like
quite simple Python - 7 + scrappy what
is your 4 + SQLite or any other DBMS for
a single process or for distributed
process you can use HBase or our DBMS
and for message bus it's possible to use
your mq or Kafka 0 mq is much more
lightweight you don't have to install
anything and if you deal with Kafka it's
a huge beast you have to install
zookeeper and probably allocate some
brokers and so on and if you if you use
if you're going to do a broad crawl then
it's but it's quite possible you will
need a DNS service so the main features
of Frontera is
online operation scheduling a new batch
DB state so that means you don't have to
stop the whole Kroll you just can stop a
single strategy worker adjust the
crawling strategy and then start it
again the same could be done there
spiders and DB workers so the system can
be like disabled like partially and you
don't have to stop the whole thing this
is not true for example when you deal
with a patchy notch
it is completely badge so first you
crawl then you parse then your schedule
new links and then you parse again then
you crawl again so when you crawl
you can't parse so it's batched and here
it has online design model and you can
do some adjustments on the fly so you
have a storage abstraction you can
implement your own storage back-end or
you can use HBase or sequel ok which are
included later we will add Cassandra and
what else may be MongoDB
it has several run mode single process
and distributed spiders and distributed
back and distributed spiders is when you
have a single worker and many spiders
which is like for some use cases is
enough but if it is not you can use the
tributed back-end like when you have
multiple DB workers multiple strategy
workers and a lot of spiders and it all
down in scrappy akka system so we have
pretty good documentation i believe in
big community and pretty easy to pretty
easy to customize in Frontera we also
have a message bus abstraction so
theoretically you can write your own
message bus but dataflow is quite
complex so it even takes me to implement
a new message bus probably like few
weeks
it's this kind of a tricky process and
we also have a crawling strategy
abstraction so you can implement your
own crawling strategy in a separate
module we are polite by design so if you
crawl abroad if you do a broad crawl you
don't want to generate too much requests
for a single website so politeness is a
good thing but every day faced with a
situation that many people don't want to
be polite like they take linkit in and
start the bomb bit with a lot of queries
and ask me like guys how can I make
Frontera to generate more queries
because it's like what I want so this is
a tricky situation so yeah of course I
tell them how to do this so I also have
a canonical Europe attraction so this is
a tricky thing when in the Internet
every document could have many euros so
when you do the crawling you have to
somehow identify some how to choose
which one would be like one you use for
identification because if you use many
rules for identification you will end up
with duplicates in your database so we
have a separate place where you can code
your own logic for canonical euro
selection and we do provide several
basic algorithms of canonical euro
resolution and all workers and spiders
are written in Python but that doesn't
limit whole thing to Python you can have
in C++ Java written spiders or any other
components because we are connected by
message bus so references please do come
to Google grabs from terror and ask us
something I am trying to build a healthy
community so you could be a part of it
we have a some future plans so soon we
should get bite in free support and
docker images we participate in the
google Summer of Code and we hired some
good students to make us viton free
compatible and to provide docker images
to rust we also want to make a web UI so
you will be able to see how crawl
performs what's the speed what's a
health check
what's a health state of all the
components of Frontera we also want to
make watchdogs solutions so it would be
possible to track website content
changes and get a notification about it
just out of the box and many other
things so I encourage you to run your
business using Frontera because we are
like scalable open customizable and it's
made in scraping hub router subscribers
so we try to build a very high quality
product
so I also encourage you to contribute
because it's an open source project so
you can submit a pull request we will
look into it and try to integrate it in
Frontera we do hire people to tell us
what to do if you feel yourself a good
developer please reach out to us I was
obliged to put it you know I'm in
general and they also they always want
to sell something so we do have our
cloud-based platform scrappy cloud it
works pretty well
pretty reliable so you can run your
spiders there we also have a smart proxy
rotator so it's black what
okay so this is essentially very
important when you crawl LinkedIn or
Google or something like this because
they do have fun t-bone protection and
you do need proxies and we also have our
own data sets so it's possible we do
collect data from several big websites
and it's possible to get the already
collected and clean data sets from us so
that's it thank you very much for
listening